all right Ted well some parents are in
high alert tonight after receiving a
letter about a recent case of
tuberculosis now it was discovered at
jetstrup elementary which is near
Tropicana and Decatur the school's
principal sent a letter to parents
saying in part recently a person was
diagnosed with active pulmonary
tuberculosis the Southern Nevada Health
District is working with us to discuss
possible student health concerns and
create a testing plan for close contacts
the letter went on to say that they're
contacting everyone who was in close
contact neither the school nor snhd had
disclosed if it was a student or a staff
member that tested positive for TB